hey guys what you're about to watch is a
super rad video I think you know I can
get super random and just grab like I
want to be like hey I don't know about
about one of those blah blah blah days
turned into I'm going to pick 30 view
and you get your ass to New York City
and I'll let you pitch me for a minute
or two and I'll jam with you for a
minute or two and I took thirty random
winners we got them all together at
Hudson Yards in New York City and what
you're about to watch now is their
pitches and my reactions and my big hope
is that we scale the content so that you
guys get to see it so that you can see
yourself in some of these pitches and
get advice that brings you value so I
hope you enjoy it and I hope you pay
attention to me on Instagram and
snapchat and and are prepared for the
next ridiculous random [ __ ] thing I
come up with my name is Amanda Gerber I
mean this Angela's front part bombing
and I what if it is my name is Daniel
Tosh I would I didn't know right my name
is Tasha I'm John patrone I am Joe
Harris my name is WOD also Boris tell me
Robert one internet for service of peop
media networking I was tested up a
company is carrying hot
d-roc I think you should talk to that
like you or somebody has to basically be
like look this is a hundred percent
going to be two minutes and 30 seconds
but we're legitimately not stretching it
because we have to be empathetic and
Gary is a major client on the back end
so make sure they know right before they
even come
all right very nice person Bishop CEO of
TG Media Network and toss we're in
eSports for lunch a combination
aspiration I'm going to be depositing or
we're super excited about building
original programming around sports love
an opportunity to work with Eurasia your
company with your grant if somebody is
got the production capabilities is there
have you worked as consultants or
gateways to the talent or creative
architect like write your
entrepreneurial right and you said you
said you have ambition to be a media
company so even though you're the
production arm you have ambitions to be
the tspn box or vice spice by severe
yeah missions are all yes some menial
absolutely finally got a 10 pitch Gary
on our eSports production company with
aspiration to be a media company
I love it please sit how are you sir -
pleasure hope that you know that all by
no Solano's I just get justice of like
needs many thanks yeah I did hear real
great just just particular idea - you're
real good artist yeah I draw a pain
arena Stan
yeah see your sense so I was thinking of
a very simple app both in the City area
so if you were to go to Target I'm gone
before you get them in on it - so you're
trying to replicate the phenomenon of
Secret Santa in app form at scale yeah
biggest first recommendation immediately
you need a co-founder who's a tech
builder or they were just like searching
place meetup.com go to meetup.com
go to LA area development Meetup shake
hands find somebody else that's cool
like you and making your partner
perfect so good I think a real pleasure
thank you sir
very nice meeting you thanks for coming
out if you really okay really well here
Ultimo's always I'm full-time stamp
along for kids six another so I'm
pitching to you today my size muscle so
basically I'm a do it here I love this
basket so what I do is I get people
about natural and holistic health and I
help to point them as to the essential
oils that would be best for them and
their family to serve their health goals
okay so when you get somebody's
attention and they're like yes I want to
use you howdy
how did your sign also work do they pay
you monthly do they buy the oil from you
what the business itself yeah I meet up
with them one-on-one and they find a way
on sale and you make a big in them in
the margin you make a commission yeah I
mean look it's much of you know the
answers it's so much content the one
thing I would say is influencers are
grossly underpriced if you really want
to do this like I really think you
should be DMing more 5 or 10 more like I
really believe in it and the other thing
is Twitter search I would search the
terms of the oil and the industry you're
in on Twitter and engaging conversations
I mean how much on an average day are
you able to put into that when the kids
are about right like nine dead then not
right so you just have to be patient
that you're going to get three our
results and you just you can't veer away
from what's tried-and-true
just because you only have three hours
it's amazing and as far as I can let you
know that a couple months ago my house
actually had burned down and it's kind
of that is that same day I found out
from Sean Young here today awesome this
is your book wrote a note from my own
tea house swear to God
as a massage that though this is like a
really life-changing opportunity I got
hang with every
okay oh yeah yeah everyone was okay but
I was blogging tonight my dad called my
friend keep rolling for some reason get
there this happened and as I'm doing
that Shawn DMV and how like the most
mixed feelings ever you know like like
I'm eating Garrity but my phone's dead
so I love my husband very much I do not
I feel but which I'm not sure confirmed
being dead or your house burger yeah I'd
be a same terrible tragedy be doing I
don't mean to might have a person yes so
they were really large where were you
Michigan understand reside okay also I
mean I represent innovative media group
of civic development on an innovative in
Fayetteville production company founded
by John petrol each other their king um
over the years we've done various
services but in the last year we decided
to focus specifically on real estate and
that coverage is in order to write me
I'm strong business
yes right you're doing the event and
dependence of real estate commercial
relative little bay area matter most
using drone footage yeah because our
production team is doing one more drone
work there might be something smarter so
you are - yes sir you do this it on like
this um how big is it right now we've
got a lot of freelance guys on like four
of us during this year you think last
year is 54,000 my goal with 120 this
year I'm interested Cimino thanks sir
appreciate thank you yeah we would have
had to like there DMO know how they
connected get the pretty much he'll be
hearing more of a Tamiya group and we're
a the question how are you
we're so excited thank you man so we're
going to pitch sort of we got up we
don't know what you were expecting so
we're just a brand with a purpose how do
we get to the next level you know what I
wear what level are you at right now
we're making about maybe two hundred
thousand we used as a custom word and
rank sales as well you know 7:00 p.m. to
3:00 o'clock in the morning DMing hip
hop artist until your [ __ ] face falls
off I genuinely believe what I'm about
to say if 21 Savage if chance took a
chance the rapper goes on stage wearing
something that is uniquely your design
right like straight up it will change
your business
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now imagine you can put big fall
sunscreen or other influencers focusing
in the handle of that I tend to think
now this really possible keep talking or
tap that app or social app discovery and
recommendations in person we've made the
app first closure it is your social
networks and what combining with the
outsiders and understood someone
occasionally if I download your app what
happens although the absolutely I lose
half the ones you want to share I get
worried about it being only valuable to
very small percentage of people if you
were about to show me some way that I'm
super like I really want a to cut an app
that says share the homescreen and for
some reason for somebody to do that and
away we go the data matters so what's
going on Gary my name is Bhavik you Wow
lo you already know let's go I'm here at
the guaranty show I'm actually the
co-founder and CEO of econ success
agency where our company focuses on
building done-for-you Shopify stores we
manage their products manager
advertising very similar to a social
media company to specifically focus on
versus if you're worried that people
getting scared off that Amazon is going
to eat it all up that's not going to
happen
yet you have to make each client that
you get profitable enough that you can
then hire somebody to help you scale and
you basically have to decide how much
money you need to live it's just running
a business how much money are you going
to take home how profitable is every one
of your customers and who can you afford
healthy scale you permissibly its
patients how do you go from this to this
hog or this is [ __ ] 20 years in the
making
you can do it you just got to be locked
into doing it nice and slow into having
to take 20 years that's the part of the
wave one
thank you sir I'm a social media
consultant and author when I read the
depressive I started working for the
Prince a Canadian ESPN in Montreal I was
wondering if I could either help you
with something gives you given me so
much thank you help and either give some
time to help with the pain or sport you
have the chance to learn from that to
import it for hypothesis we have a
couple guys in the Canadian Football
League and maybe you can go and produce
some content with the video production
arm that you have let me give us a spot
send me an email or I'm going to put in
my Vayner Sports folder thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi hi I'm April April such a pleasure
for cooking
what's cooking is tromelin corn
processes and Martha's important so
proudly so what I like to commit
yourself who you've invested all this
money into athletes and what's your
insurance policy that's right right so
you have an athlete who's playing and
the integer or something happens and I
don't have that piece that skill set
that helps them either exit from sports
gracefully or keeps them within it yep
tamo believe ernest keep talking so it
would be your dream scenario here is
that Boehner supports hires you to work
with our athletes so what if they don't
have trauma you're not involved
so me personally so much understood so
it's the definition of that is that is
that branding off because I actually
agree with you
thank you that everybody like I think
everybody should have a third force I
don't think it's branded at all I didn't
have trauma but I would have I turned
out [ __ ] unbelievable and would have
taken a third force this is the only
thing on about the brain is your
operating system send and you live my
bleep I live what I mean I know what I
got it drop it trust me I don't think
just because I I think everybody should
do it yet thank you such a pleasure
Gary wants to follow up my email so I
would say the fact you can get in having
you know a couple minutes thank you guys
what can help you uh uh I mean you know
I got a business card Nicholson Burnett
it's pretty much like a buy sell trade
business like only kind of like you know
like be inside yeah I like that polite
is like like I'm pivoting into by does
the media apart okay I want to use like
the media to ashley language a brand
iconic role like majority of the
business is like pretty much as we tail
and everything you don't pretty decently
sales
how are you selling it like goodwill
doubtless the warehouse and being polite
you're doing the party gosh yeah like
the whole thing that I like believe in
the motion where's the stuff selling
through Braille eBay offer all these
play all of this and it's the same user
brand-name everywhere yeah and what is
the one more time literally brother I
don't think you should worry about it
yet
yes I'm giving you a little bit of a
curveball even though I believe media is
everything yes I think you have a
natural ability to flip I think you
should put a hundred percent of your
effort because when you get that Bank up
and you're doing a million dollars in
the arbitrage you'll be a little higher
for the media play you're trying to
solve a problem you don't have yet you
went from zero to a hundred twenty
thousand revenue run rate yeah without
anybody knowing your [ __ ] brand my
intuition is you can get the five
million that way and nobody gives a [ __ ]
about the brand you can be seller seller
49 on all these platforms and it doesn't
matter
you're smart which is why you got to
where you are already that is going to
matter you're looking to make it matter
too soon just be patient what you're
doing is right save dollars make profit
don't buy [ __ ] for yourself
yeah poor every dollar back into the
business or into savings you'll be more
than on your way you've got to figure it
out keep going this arbitrage retail
arbitrage
is real don't even look up don't even
look up for air for another two years
being dead serious
yeah cuz you're gonna pick up your head
and gonna have a lot of money it's not
going anywhere
yeah this arbitrage exists no idea
appreciate it you're welcome
oh my enlightenment what I should do
next in life just keep my ear down we
keep pounding it out but right now like
very salem is a cute [ __ ]
[Music]
you